foreign
welcome back to our Channel today we
have an exciting topic to dive into what
are microservices
you may have heard this buzzword
floating around in the world of software
development but what exactly are
microservices well in this video we'll
not only uncover the answer but also
explore the advantages challenges and
even some real life examples of
companies using microservices so let's
get started but before that for more
such interesting videos do subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update from simp
leader and if you want to learn more
about cloud computing Concepts and
services and its various other cloud
computing platforms then our Caltech
cloud computing bootcamp will be the
right choice for you this cloud
computing bootcamp will help you become
an expert in Azure and AWS
this in-depth cloud computing online
bootcamp course lets you master key
architecture principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud exporter
it will help you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementation our cloud computing
course helps you master the core skill
sets required to design and deploy
dynamically scalable and reliable
applications on Microsoft Azure and AWS
so do check out the course link
mentioned in the description so let's
get started with the video but before we
jump into microservices let's start with
the traditional way of building
applications known as monolithic
architecture now in the world of
software development monolithic
architecture refers to a structure where
all the components of an application are
tightly integrated into a single
monolithic unit it's like having a
massive building where everything from
the foundation to the roof is
interconnected
architecture has its advantages it also
comes with some challenges
imagine updating a single feature of
your application with monolithic
architecture you have to recompile and
redeploy the entire application which
can be time consuming and risky
this can slow down the development
process and make it harder to scale and
maintain the application
and that's when enters microservices
instead of a monolithic building think
of a microservice as a collection of
small independent buildings that work
together to create a powerful
application but what exactly are
microservices
well microservices are an architectural
style that structures an application as
a collection of loosely coupled services
each serving a specific business
capability these Services communicate
with each other through apis allowing
them to work together harmoniously in a
microservice architecture each service
focuses on doing one thing and doing it
well for example you can have a user
service and inventory service and a
payment service each service can be
redeveloped redeployed and scaled
independently enabling faster
development cycles and easier
maintenance but how do these
microservices interact with each other
well they communicate through
well-defined apis using lightweight
protocols like HTTP or messaging systems
like rabbit mq this decouple
communication allows each service to
evolve independently without impacting
the entire system microservices interact
with each other using various
communication protocols and mechanism
and here are some common ways
microservices interact first one is rest
apis now microservices often expose rest
apis that allow communication over HTTP
each microservice typically has its own
set of endpoints representing different
resources and operations Services can
make HTTP requests to the appropriate
endpoints to exchange data and invoke
functionalities of other microservices
second is messaging queues now
microservices can communicate
asynchronously through messaging queues
one microservice can publish messages to
a queue and other microservices can
consume those messages
this decouples the service allowing them
to operate independently
popular messaging systems include
rabbitmq Apache Kafka and activemq third
is service Discovery now in a
microservice environment where Services
can be dynamically scaled and deployed
across multiple instances service
Discovery becomes crucial service
Discovery enables microservices to
locate and communicate with each other
without hard coding IP address or
endpoints it provides a centralized
mechanism for registering discovering
and resolving the network location of
services then comes orchestration
microservices orchestration involves
managing the interaction and
coordination between multiple
microservices to accomplish in a
specific business process or workflow
orchestration typically involves a
central component called an orchestrator
that controls the execution and
sequencing of microservices but it's
worth noting that the choice of
interaction mechanism depends on the
specific requirement and constraints of
the system some system May rely on a
combination of these approaches to meet
their communication needs
now let's talk about key characteristics
of microservices so the first one is
microservices are highly decoupled each
service can be developed deployed and
maintained independently providing
flexibility and Agility in the
development process
second is microservices are scalable you
can scale Individual Services based on
the specific needs allowing you to
optimize resource allocation and handle
increased user demand more effectively
third microservices are fault tolerant
if one service fails it doesn't brings
down the entire application the fault is
isolated and other services can continue
to function and lastly microservices
promote technology diversity
each service can be built using
different programming languages
Frameworks and databases depending on
what works best for that specific
service
now you might be wondering who is using
microservices well many big names
companies have adopted this
architectural style companies like
Netflix Amazon and Spotify have
leveraged microservices to build
scalable resilient and Innovative
application and there you have it a
glimpse into the world of microservices
from the characteristics to the benefits
and real world examples microservices
have revolutionize the way we build and
scale applications here's a success
story of one of our Learners to boost
your confidence do watch this video
and I am currently living in Algeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a personal
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing and association with
caltech.com video that with this course
I had the choice to study while
and that is how I got this new job offer
with 60 salary high in Finland I will be
leading the cloud computing unit of my
new company we cannot wait to start our
new life in Finland we are also thank
you for joining me on this journey if
you found this video helpful don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe for more exciting content
until next time happy coding staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you